io non so da dove sta arrivando tutta
quest'area di preciso ma magari chiudere
la finestra belle tutti ragazzi e
prevenuti questo nuovo video sono fa vj
ed oggi siamo su hotel a cinque stelle
con camera con idromassaggio
ma se fosse dungeon nightmares non so
ancora bene come è fatta la location è
tutto quanto però dal menu posso vedere
che più bella di camera mia ragazzi ogni
sera dell iphone sigli recommend
cimitero raccomandano di utilizzare le
cuffie pro per prendersi gli infarti
giustini ragazzi dire che ci siamo
facciamo finta di nulla
entriamo come se cosa devo cliccare qui
dungeon ex art night one si nasconde
nell'ombra non è molto rassicurante come
consiglio proprio grazie al loro prezzo
perché ho ragazzi siano partiti dover
nelle gambe a bellissimo di raccogliere
candele poi ci sono le cantine anche la
torcia ma la candela potente cosa c'è a
si apre fanta bellissimo non potevo
desiderare il meglio quanta cazzo di
roba che non dovevate fantastico cioè
come si aprono le porte questo lucchetto
bellissimo ma le porte a veramente per
aprire il vostro 32 euro
tua madre il calore che tale infilo
nello scrigno di prima che cazzo urlich
le cuffie lo rendono veramente speciale
un giorno poi c'è il quadro abbiamo qui
vai che va da appendere in camera vorrei
prendere davanti al letto che la mattina
quando mi sveglio mi da la carica giusta
e la cosa fai a studiarla adesso ci
incontriamo un attimo ci parli io vado
di qua perché c'è una porta chiusa mi
piace di più se tazza di a spuntare
minchia tardiva non è rispuntato niente
perfetto che cazzo è una mostra che
senta ma anche lei per caso aspettava
l'autobus qui perché vedo che sta
attendendo da molto comunque
lui pensava che fossi io l'autobus ma
non ero io quindi è morto va bene senza
bella e questa cosa è una candela perché
trovo che io che trova candele in giro a
caldo questo entrato di qua non ero
entrato di qua e di qua non ci vado alla
ragazzi andiamo ad altra parte perché è
però entrato nella porta sbagliata mi sa
che è entrato di qualche effetto ma
ripensandoci turn ovvero prima è il
gelato che aspetta autobus per faticoso
sono che da fuori a [ __ ] monito alla
ragazzina scola temo che ci avrei
scommesso qualsiasi cosa eccessiva
un'acqua tra l'altro nuovo vista cos'è
sta merda ma ci sono leggermente un po
distanze mi dico al como visto qualcuno
prima che non mi è piaciuto per niente
però devo andarci per forza io vado in
giro promosse vie e bauli trovate minuti
di tagli steve auley lingotti lingo sono
in gotti trovo in giro perfetto ma se
tema ragazzi vi chiama organizziamo una
festa qua dentro voci state non paghi
che salverà è svenuto e svenuto in un
altro tizio perfetto che diamo via
muoviamo leggermente culo perché io sto
qua detto sorpreso non credere a nessuno
che incontri qua sto ringrazio per il
consiglio ma non è questa gente mi sfidi
tanta fiducia sinceramente comunque
apprezzo consiglio grazie mille per
avermelo dato però non li credevo a
prescindere ok non aspettare attimo che
ogni voto apre una porta con il cavo
addosso perché ho paura agli sputi
qualcuno perfetto non è spuntato nessuno
grazie a di ormea show
un'altra pasta se porta il mio dio in
questo sempre all'interno non c'e
nessuno però sentono maria cazzo
fantastico
a tipo una lucetta la mettiamo visto
giocano perché non ad un cazzo se va in
mezz'ora che vado avanti a al buio
praticamente ci siamo livellante calmi
in attimo perché quanti camera ci sono
qua dentro
oddio ho trovato la miniera di candele
rega perfetto artefatto trovato trova
l'uscita sarà perfetto ragazzi ho
trovato non so non c'era un libro io non
so chi è menomato mentale che entrerebbe
qua dentro per un libro per hobby per un
buongiorno
c'è un tizio già lo vedo molto è ma è
molto magro prova becco sicuro si può
rimediare
l'uscita non dite di temi che hanno
scelta ragazzi ordina una pizza poiché
si vede che hai fame però io esco ok ok
sì sì sì ho fatto l'ho fatta non ci
posso giurarlo ragazzi già fatti si è
svegliato alle due alle 20 1 preciso
sono tornato al menu quindi credo siano
stato start nights ii si nasconde l'ho
capito che si nasconde nella ormai è
un'altra cosa questa notte due di sette
ma se io premo m tipo
ok non ho finito proprio un cazzo
credevo di aver finito ma era più che
altro mio desiderio
e non so neanche a partito che ha come
meno due passi me li fai fare sto tizio
e dunque credo che lo chiamerò zio
bobbio qualcosa del genere di merda dato
una botta alla sedia incredibile senti
zio bobby allora veri non prevedo il
cazzo che mamma mia ke bello che sei
sembra di essere al museo delle
olimpiadi di corsa un qualcosa del
genere io vado vado avanti dico anche se
non ho capito bene dove sto andando
perché non c'è io devo trovare un
oggetto in particolare e trovare
l'uscita se vincesse occupato si dice
occupato non così al mio calmi ok non è
preoccupato perfetto ma ragazzi usano
cosa cosa è successo non ho visto niente
di tutto questo ci piglia male a
prescindere dalla serata ok non lo sa ed
è controllato da un giorno vaiasicca 5
you di bob affanculo prima regata
sfondando la porta
no no no non ho cliccato ho sbagliato la
tecnica le sbaglia tecnica
day time i cani kakà america america è
vista [ __ ] ragazzi non ho capito
dove sto andando
c'è una tizia molto brutta co so lo so
che c'è qualcosa lo so lo so non c'è un
cazzo perfetto ha proceduto bobby non
rompermi le palle mentre propri
assistiti perché devo trovare qualcosa
dentro che non sara che lo zio bobby mi
sta facendo una povera pazza io io io
non mi ci dovrebbe capire che marca la
frutta
io aiuto non si è chiusa s'è chiusa la
porta pausa un attimo perché mi sto
morendo
no no dover iniziare no non fatevi
questo veramente devono iniziare
giochiamo con due tre stella quando mi
giro ho timori della accennato il
movimento ma non l'ha fatto per farli
devi scappare ma tua sorella delle
scappa linosa non sei mai da solo cosa
c'entri mobile c'è lo zio mobile è morto
zio ben e paziente trovare che sto
girando da mezz'ora non ho ancora capito
gli altri matrici perfetto ho trovato la
cazzo di uscita mi manca neethling devo
trovare qualcosa di sicuro assurdo sì sì
sì sì ragazzo lo fanno non fate domande
non lo so come come ho fatto avere il
suo culo non lo so si è svegliata dal
cibo e 36 grazie mille però preferivo
dormire va bene tutto ma costano ti sta
più tartassando le palle chiudi le porte
per ora rallentarli vabbè questo l'avevo
capito che cazzo ci han cagato sul muro
senti dio no anzi o no zio non hai
capito un cazzo zio
io prima che trovò germano capito una
cosa ma siccome non so se è un caso che
ho trovato pavimento ho trovato latte
fatto vicino all'uscita attaccherà aveva
appiccicato all'uscita non so se è un
caso ancora bobby
no no no no no no no no no non fai
perfetto alla cena con la tizia che
rompe le palle
quindi meglio lasciar perdere veloci lo
zio bobby ferma la bobby veloce potetti
quantico di cosa sta succedendo fermi
fermi che questo rallenta perché
ovviamente mangia i panini del mcdonald
è finito che sa correre un attimino che
no no no non mi sta raggiungendo
velocemente alcune melo melo mette meno
mette non me lo versa via via via via di
avere l'ok veloce però mica mezz'ora
ogni volta poiché ha buttato là qualche
brutta ok no no no no no no no la stanza
chiudono dentro gli open days vari no
non l'ho nemmeno nella merda ma
[ __ ] sapevo non mi ha ucciso però
non l'ho chiusa dentro ragazzi non mi
oggi non fate domande non so come sia
possibile ma non ho ucciso non ho
neanche capito come ha fatto annunci da
mino va bene così non facciamoci domanda
che è meglio se si grande basta devo
riuscire abbia mai bisogno di uscire
grazie grazie ai consigli e bellissimo
giurano veramente non non avrei mai
detto guarda il vento che cazzo stallo
sì lo sapevo ma na botta di culo cose io
non voglio più giocare la sta merda
e stato io vi giuro è stato traumatico
ti sei svegliato alle 4 27
no mi sono rimesso a dormire perché non
me ne frega una mazza di staristi posti
ok buongiorno anche a te zio allora
sentite un attimo dove devo andare
allora siccome non ho capito già trovata
a caso siamo a 5 che culo pazzesco lei
ti stai aspettando guarda lei ti sto
aspettando prima come te lo aspetti che
ti stia aspettando come realmente
precede una cosa è partito un gomito ma
è partito ma va bene non ho capito che
mi metto a fare per si strani anche a
noi che ci ha paura pure loro no perché
due capisce un cazzo zio stai fermo
preti fico lo zio mica se mi fai uno
schema guarda che ti infila la candela
nel culo giuro
giuro giuro c'è una porta per me ne
frega un cazzo si se no te quante ne
manca 2 cioè non so se vi rendete conto
quanta strada ho fatto 100 ho fatto
tutto cio e non ho ancora trovato
l'artefatto meraviglioso ragazzi o 6 ci
mette roma
sono nuovi di ragazzi sugli piangi
infatti no no no no no sono strade
secondarie sono morto
sono ma [ __ ] ma ce la farò mai a
finire a livello sei ragazzi questo è
sicuro io non so quanto quanti anni
sommesso arrivare fino a livello 6 ma
questi sono pazzi
va bè ragazzi re che posso concludere
qui per questo episodio perché no
effettivamente sette livelli in una sola
volta non mi va di di farli non so boni
giardino è piaciuto come asserito lascia
trattamento mi piace anche a parla di
facebook e come la divido tratta nella
descrizione delle sere crisi iscrivetevi
che ci rivediamo il passeur vitobello
ragazzi